starting uh a little late because uh
someone was late
someone was a little late
do you have any defense for your
tardiness the traffic was
heavy i tried to be on time the traffic
it's always something the traffic
well you said you were going to record
it three and then
i was doing a thing with my wife i was
that a thing
you know i mean i had to run from it and
then
you had to run from the thing you were
doing yeah we didn't do your job
there was a friend in austin who was in
town and you had to run
from the friend to your job well you
said we were gonna record at four then
you moved it to three
so so i moved it your job was moved
and you had to leave why don't you go
back to the friend
let's just do the show let's you go back
to your friend i think it's better for
you to go back to your friend
dad's here please go back to your friend
i who's going to produce the show
i'll figure it out i'll figure it out
it's insane
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show uh
beautiful day in austin texas a mass
shooting downtown